Where did the virus
that changed the world come from?
For a long time, the prevailing theory was
that wild animals like
bats sold at a wet market
in Wuhan, China had started the outbreak.
One of the first scientists to question
this narrative was Botao
Xiao, who on February 6th,
distributed a paper arguing
that the killer coronavirus
probably originated from
a laboratory in Wuhan.
The author pointed out
that there was no evidence
that the vendors at the wet
market in Wuhan sold bat meat.
On the other hand, there
were two research labs
studying bat-born
coronaviruses located in Wuhan
where a virus could have
accidentally infected workers
causing them to spread the
disease to the general public.
Botao Xiao withdrew the
paper two weeks later
after Chinese authorities declared
that the lab leak theory had no merit.
China is being accused
of censoring critical data
about the coronavirus.
The renowned law professor
at Tsinghua University in
Beijing Xu Zhangrun, is known
to be missing after publicly condemning
Chinese president Xi Jinping for failing
to contain the spread of
the virus at an early stage.
The Chinese government proceeded
to clamp down on research
into the virus's origins.
New regulations
restricting the publication
of research about coronavirus.
Any paper that traces the origin
of the virus should be strictly managed.
To this day, the Chinese
government won't allow
outside researchers to test blood drawn
from employees of the Wuhan lab,
who may have been among
the first humans infected
with COVID in November of 2019.
According to the official record,
they were hospitalized with
pneumonia-like disease.
There's no proof that the
virus originated from a lab,
but there's also no proof that
humans first became infected
by eating bat or exposure to pangolin,
a theory that was treated
as unimpeachable fact
early in the pandemic.
A group of scientists
signed a statement published
in The Lancet denouncing speculation
about non-natural origins of the virus
as conspiracy theories.
Only after some emails became
public id it become clear
that the scientists who
brought his colleagues together
to co-sign The Lancet statement was
Peter Daszak, head of
the EcoHealth Alliance,
the nonprofit that secured
US government funding
for controversial research
on bat-born coronaviruses
at the Wuhan Institute of Virology.
Daszak also coauthored a June 2020 op-ed
in The Guardian headlined,
Ignore the conspiracy theories:
scientists know COVID-19
wasn't created in the lab,
without disclosing a potential
conflict of interest.
Media coverage following the publication
of The Lancet letter
overwhelmingly framed discussion
of the lab leak hypothesis
as conspiracy theory.
That episode does not
reflect well on science.
Science writer Matt Ridley says
that Anthony Fauci's private
emails, which were made public
through a Freedom of
Information Act request,
show that behind the scenes scientists
were taking the lab leak
theory seriously all along.
A number of leading
virologists were talking
to each other and we're
saying to each other,
we think this might
look a bit like a virus
that's been engineered in a laboratory.
And then they all got on a
phone call with Anthony Fauci,
and at the end of that phone call,
they all did a very rapid about-face
and started writing
articles almost immediately.
And in the case of Peter Daszak,
the fact that he had
orchestrated the letter was not
at all clear until emails were leaked.
It does raise very serious concerns
that Dr. Daszak needs to answer.
I've tried to correspond
with him numerous times.
I've never yet had a response.
Daszak also didn't reply to
Reason's interview request.
Ridley has co-authored "Viral,"
a new book about the ongoing hunt
for the origins of the coronavirus.
His writing partner is
Broad Institute of MIT
and Harvard scientist Alina Chan,
one of the earliest and most
outspoken public skeptics
of the natural origin hypothesis.
She says that when she and her colleagues
published a pre-print
questioning the consensus
that she hadn't been aware
of The Lancet letter organized by Daszak,
but that she believes it
could have had a major
chilling effect on the
scientific discussion
in those early days.
So they're saying that anyone who's saying
that this virus didn't come from
nature is a conspiracy theorist.
People, when they read this
letter, they might have thought,
then I'm not going to
put my neck out there
to say that this might
have come from a lab.
Chan, a molecular biologist,
argued in the paper that because
SARS-CoV-2 was so well adapted to humans,
there was reason to be skeptical
that it had recently come from an animal.
If it had recently come
from bats or pangolins,
she would have expected the virus
to have been rapidly
mutating in the early days
of the pandemic to become
better adapted to human tissue.
For the, the light bulb moment was when
I read in the news that the
novel coronavirus SARS-CoV-2,
a pure genetically stable.
Chan credits this insight partially
to her experience living through
the SARS outbreak of 2003,
which she lived through in Singapore.
In that situation, in that outbreak,
the virus had rapidly picked
up dozens of mutations
in the early three months of the outbreak.
In comparison for SARS-CoV-2,
there are very few of these mutations.
So it suggested to me that this
virus had already picked up
many useful mutations for infecting
and transmitting amongst humans prior
to its detection in December 2019.
Another major difference is that
during the 2003 outbreak,
authorities discovered
previous SARS infections
among animals being sold
at markets in South China
within a couple of months.
That's not the case with SARS-CoV-2,
despite initial suspicions
that a seafood market was to blame.
In the case of SARS-2,
even though the first
class of cases identified
was at the seafood market,
they never found any signs of animals
that were infected by this virus.
So up till today, there's
no sign of an animal
that was ever infected by SARS-CoV-2
and then gave it to humans.
When the World Health
Organization sent a team
to investigate the viruses
origins in January 2021,
EcoHealth Alliances Daszak was the only
American member included.
The team dismissed the lab leak hypothesis
before WHO leadership later backtracked.
The findings suggest
the laboratory incidents
hypothesis is extremely unlikely
and to explain the introduction
of the virus into the human population.
And therefore, is not an
hypothesis that we suggest
that implies to suggest future studies.
Daszak granted an interview
to 60 Minutes following that trip to Wuhan
and suggested that farm animals
were the likely culprit.
But there's no direct evidence that any
of those animals were actually
infected with the bat virus.
Correct.
Now what we've got to
do is go to those farms
and investigate, talk to the farmers,
talk to their relatives, test them,
see if there were spikes
in virus there first.
So the team doesn't actually know if any
of the farmers or the
truckers were ever infected.
No one knows yet.
No one's been there, no one's asked them,
no one's tested them.
That's to be done.
There's a detail that emerged
after the "60 Minutes" report that
Ridley would like Daszak to explain.
Recently leaked documents show that
EcoHealth Alliance applied
for a research grant related
to inserting what's called
a furin cleavage site
into SARS-like coronaviruses.
This very furin cleavage
site make SARS-CoV-2
highly infectious in humans
and it's what distinguishes it from any
SARS-like coronaviruses
yet found in the wild.
The grant request was rejected,
but did the Wuhan laboratory
engage in this research
even without funding from that grant?
Daszak may be able to help
to answer that question.
The fact that that is probably the feature
that makes the virus
sufficiently infectious
to start a pandemic means that
it is a highly important thing.
So you would think that
a scientist who knew
that he had put in a
grant application in 2018
to put furin cleavage site
into SARS-like viruses
and admittedly been turned down
at the Wuhan Institute of
Virology would volunteer
that information early in the pandemic
so as to help us understand this new virus
and understand where
it might've come from.
Ridley and Chan also find it suspicious
that when China's premier
bat coronavirus expert
and Daszak's collaborator
in Wuhan published
her complete analysis of
the SARS-CoV-2 genome,
she neglected to mention
this highly unusual
furin cleavage site, but
Daszak told "60 Minutes"
that the WHO did look
into the lab leak theory.
You're just taking their word for it.
Well, what else can we do?
There's a limit to what you can do
and we went right up to that limit.
We asked them tough questions.
They weren't vetted in advance.
And the answers they gave we found
to be believable, correct, and convincing.
But weren't the Chinese
engaged in a coverup?
They destroyed evidence.
They punished scientists who were trying
to give evidence on this
very question of the origin.
Well, that wasn't our task to find out
if China had covered up.
It was the behavior of someone
who is trying to ensure
that one message got out
and not another, which is
fine if you're a politician
or some kind of opinionated person
and scientists should be
allowed their own opinion.
But it's not fine if you
are being asked to be part
of an objective
international investigation
with privileged access.
After the "60 Minutes" interview,
leaked documents showed that
EcoHealth Alliance worked
with the Wuhan Institute of Virology
to make several bat-born
SARS-like coronaviruses,
and even MERS more
infectious to human cells.
Chan and Ridley say that when
they started writing the book,
they didn't have a strong view
about which theory was correct.
But these recent revelations
have shifted their thinking in
favor of the lab leak theory.
In light of grant proposals
and reports released
within the past few months,
Chan wrote on Twitter,
we know novel SARS-like
viruses were being synthesized
and engineered at unprecedented scale.
That changed my mind completely.
So knowing that there actually was a plan,
a pipeline, a protocol for
doing this work in 2018.
So now for me, genetic
engineering is very much
on the table.
It's not just a one out of 10,000 chance
that this might have happened if it came
from a lab close to 50 percent
chance that it happened.
This question was at the center
of a heated exchange between Anthony Fauci
and Senator Rand Paul
over possible NIH funding
of so-called gain of function research,
which involves purposely making a virus
more infectious to humans.
You take an animal virus
and you increase the
transferability to humans,
you're saying that's not gain of function?
That is correct.
And, Senator Paul, you do not know
what you are talking about quite frankly.
And I want to say that officially.
There will be responsibility for those
who funded the lab, including yourself.
I totally resent-
This committee will allow
the witness to respond.
I totally resent the lie
that you are now propagating, Senator.
Because if you look at the viruses
that were used in the experiments
that were given in the annual reports
that were published in the literature,
it is molecularly impossible.
No one's saying those viruses caused it.
It is molecularly-
No one is alleging
those virus cause the pandemic.
What we're alleging is that
gain of function research
was going on in that
lab and NIH funded it.
You can't get away from it.
It meets your definition and
you are obfuscating the truth.
But much of the blame
for the devastating scope
of the pandemic, says Ridley,
rests on Chinese authorities
who punished ophthalmologists Li Wenliang
who tried to get the word out
about the emergence of
a new SARS-like virus.
The government successfully
kept human to human transmission
of the disease under wraps
for weeks, maybe longer.
Why was such an angst and secrecy
even at the hyper-local level
from the very beginning?
Communist regimes tend to be secretive.
There tends to be an
assumption that you don't talk
about things unless you're allowed to,
rather than the other way round.
But Xi Jinping is a much more dictatorial
and authoritarian ruler than
his immediate predecessors.
And by 2019, it was more and more the case
that scientists in laboratories
and doctors in hospitals
were under orders not
to communicate with the outside world
about things that the regime
might not want them to.
Very significant attempts to punish
and suppress the release of information
about the epidemic that
was developing in Wuhan.
Did that play a part in
the epidemic escaping
and getting to the rest of the world
and turning into a pandemic?
You bet it did.
If on the 27th, 28th of December,
when alarm bells were beginning
to ring in hospitals in Wuhan,
the Chinese authorities
should have said to the world,
we've got a problem in Wuhan.
We're going to do our best to stop it.
Then we probably could've
pinched this in the bud
before it got out of the city of Wuhan.
The Wuhan Institute of
Virology houses samples
of RaTG13, a bat virus that is one
of the closest known genetic
matches to SARS-CoV-2.
But to this day, information
about other coronaviruses
in the Wuhan lab haven't been released
so we don't know if the lab
was working with a virus
that's even more closely
related to SARS-CoV-2.
The lab's public database of viral samples
could hold some answers,
but it was taken offline
in February and had been
modified in December,
which we know because of work by DRASTIC,
the Dedicated Research
and Scientific Team
Investigating COVID-19,
a decentralized group of volunteers
that compile and analyze
open-source material
and leaked documents to
investigate the origins of COVID.
They are the heroes of our book.
Once I realized that
it's being completely,
it's being discredited
without any evidence,
I just couldn't stay silent.
Yuri Deigin is a biotech entrepreneur
and one of the founding
members of DRASTIC.
There was just a group
of like-minded people
on Twitter who got into like
really huge long threads
on Twitter on some things like
where's the Mojiang
mine or what is RaTG13.
And then at some point, we just
went off to a private group,
which was called Daszak Fan Club,
because pretty much all of us were blocked
by Peter Daszak at some point.
A key revelation
uncovered by the group was
that the Wuhan Institute
of Virology database
was first taken down in September 2019,
three months before the
pandemic became public.
A description of the database was modified
on December 30th, 2019, the day Dr. Shi
told Chinese state
television that her lab first
obtained the samples
of the virus In Wuhan.
Wuhan scientists access
the database a few times
before it was permanently removed
in February 2020 for
alleged security concerns.
For them to take it down,
it's very suspicious.
And of course Shi Zhengli's explanation
that she took it down to prevent hackers
from attacking it is complete bullshit
because it was a public
database to begin with
and what's she afraid of?
A member of the DRASTIC
team also discovered
that the Wuhan team had
collected key samples,
including one of the virus's
closest known genetic matches
from a mine where some
workers had fallen sick
and died after clearing out bat droppings.
Chinese authorities have denied outsiders
any access to examine the mine.
All of these revelations just
reinforced our realization
that either they're not
telling the truth at all,
or they're not telling the
whole truth to the world.
And you know, that was a big moment for us
to kind of start digging
deeper and deeper.
Though there's mounting
circumstantial evidence
to support the lab leak theory,
most government officials still maintain
that the natural origin
hypothesis is more likely.
A US intelligence report declassified
on October 29th said four Intel
agencies had low confidence
that the virus most
likely emerged in nature,
one agency had moderate confidence
that it leaked from a lab
and analysts at three
agencies remained unable
to coalesce around either explanation
without additional information.
The report did conclude
that SARS-CoV-2 was unlikely
to be a biological weapon.
NIH Director Francis Collins,
who didn't reply to our interview request,
told computer scientist and
podcast host Lex Fridman
in early November that he's
open to the lab leak hypothesis,
but still believes strongly
that the virus is of natural origin.
Is there a reasonable chance
that COVID-19 leaked from a lab?
I can't exclude that.
I think it's fairly unlikely.
I wish we had more ability to be able
to ask questions of the Chinese government
and learn more about what kind
of records might have been
in the lab that we've
never been able to see.
But most likely, this was a
natural origin of a virus,
probably starting in a bat,
perhaps traveling through
some other intermediate
yet to be identified host and
finding its way into humans.
Between July 2020 and January 2021,
an international team of
scientists captured bats
in Laos carrying a newly
discovered coronavirus
that's the closest known
genetic match to SARS-CoV-2,
even closer than the virus
held in the Wuhan lab,
which some say supports
the natural origin theory.
But Ridley, Chan, and Deigin point out
that it lacks the crucial
furin cleavage site,
which they suspect was inserted in a lab.
Supporters of the natural
origin theory point out
that no smoking gun
virus has yet been found
in the version of the Wuhan
database uncovered by DRASTIC.
But Chan points out that this version
of the database is years out of date
because the Wuhan researchers
generally don't enter
new viruses until they've
had a chance to sequence
and publish studies about them.
The Wuhan Institute of Virology
database is still inaccessible.
We only see viruses they've
collected up to 2016.
So we have barely any
concept of what viruses
and sequences they might have found
after 2016 in the years
leading up to COVID-19.
So without access to the information
becomes very difficult for us to guess
whether or not they have
found the precursor of SARS-2
in their labs and were working with it.
Of course, also we'd
love to get that database
or at least part of the
data from the database
that's been deleted and to see
all the unpublished sequences.
I definitely don't want
to stop biotechnology.
I think CRISPR gene
editing is a fantastic tool
for medicine, for
agriculture, for conservation,
for all sorts of things.
The overwhelming majority of work
in this field has benefited mankind,
including the development of
the messenger RNA vaccines
that have saved millions
of lives in the last year.
But Ridley says that
scientists should come together
to set ethical guidelines
that prohibit dangerous types
of research such as experimenting
on bat viruses to make
them more infectious
to human cells in large urban environments
after harvesting them from caves far away
from human population centers as this
China-produced documentary
shows researchers doing,
some of them without
proper protective gear.
Going out and harvesting
viruses in wild places
and with pandemic potential
and bringing them back
to cities to work on them
probably isn't very sensible.
It's like looking for a gas leak
with a lighted match as somebody put it.
So if we could get the US,
the UK, Australia, Japan,
other major countries
to sign a treaty saying,
when there's an outbreak in our country,
we promise to open up as far as possible
and tell you everything we know,
then the very fact that
some countries won't sign
that treaty will itself
put pressure on them.
That's kind of the way
the International Atomic
Energy Authority evolved.
And I think that's what we
should be looking to achieve.
How optimistic or pessimistic are you
that we ever will get to the
truth of the matter here?
I'm generally optimistic.
I think truth will out here.
It may take a long time.
I noticed that the fall of
the Soviet Union did lead
to significant revelations about
biological accidents there,
for example, anthrax.
I think, therefore, it may take a change
of regime in Beijing
before we find out more.
But I think there are people
who know what happened,
whatever had happened, even if it's just
what happened in a market,
there are people who know.
And I can't help thinking
that at some point
we will be able to find out who they are
and ask even in a regime
as repressive and controlling as China's.
So I hope we do find out.
There are many people
who say it's too late,
we've lost the chance,
we'll never find out.
I'm not one of them, at least not yet.